[Music]
talk about their new game the Red
Lantern how you doing sailing good how
are you good good so tell about the red
Lancer yeah so it's a dogsledding
story-driven survival game where you
play as this musher who'd like set out
to do all these things in her life it
didn't quite go as well as she wanted
and she decides it a really big reset
button you know we all make rash
decisions sometimes and she decides to
go become a dog sled er and move up to
Alaska with her best buddy Chomper it
doesn't go quite as well as she would
hope so what's the the main elements of
the red Lancer it's more narrative and
exploration and survival or is it just
like a big mix of the three like what's
going on with it it's a pretty big mix
so we wanted to give you sort of a story
structure that allows you to understand
the base elements of like you know go to
Alaska start your new life get this new
home adopt four dogs to go out with you
and Chomper there's actually nine total
dogs so you have a different like build
basically each time you go out there and
then encounter the wilderness so the
wilderness you know starts out and like
you're enthusiastic you're excited about
nature but reality kind of hits you at
some point and you have to kind of
reckon with who you got who you choose
to become you know when faced with the
hardest of consequence
perfectly those challenges what kind of
unique narrative elements are we going
to see throughout red lantern yeah so
each dog has their own like mini Ark so
you're gonna help them figure out who
they want to become Berkeley the
spider's name is actually quite quiet he
tends to bite before he barks he really
wants to protect you the musher so you
want to teach him to bark before he
bites basically it helped him protect
himself and scare things away and so
you'll also encounter you know moose
weasel arctic foxes ptarmigans all the
things I've read a lot about along the
way and a whole bunch more animals in
each scene has different things that can
happen obviously you're gonna hunt to
live but you're gonna see some other
surprises along the way you could maybe
try to put a note I don't recommend it
but it is a thing so now we talked about
a little bit what to expect in the game
that's like a little I take a look at
what we're actually seeing here he break
down a little bit of what the player is
going through well he just encountered a
squirrel that Chomper was pretty excited
about and just went in and wrecked house
the squirrel is obviously small for the
kind of rifle that you have so it
exploded a little bit and everything is
a resource ultimately so he left Chomper
go out and basically eat the rest of the
squirrel so it didn't go to waste and
that's a big part of the game is we
actually want hunting gab like a lot of
meaning to it too or it's like this is
about food this is about getting to the
places that you need to get to and using
your dogs to help and as well as you you
know helping them get there so we can
see that he's like making the decisions
to go left or right you're gonna have
these different nodes sort of like you
know an FTL kind of game where you're
going into the forest or towards the
river to find the different things from
there he's probably gonna want to camp
right after he meets this little caribou
so we got we got gameplay we got this
narrative elements of the game now
the visuals the actual the way the game
looks it's gorgeous
so what's it what's the inspiration
behind that that's on here behind me now
the inspiration we've you know we study
a lot of different types of art style is
basically our background we work
together on the King's Quest episodic
series which is all hand water-colored
yes you know familiar with that yeah
yeah so we are very like an art driven
studio so it has a lot of rush textures
to it we wanted to keep it very stylized
that also helps with being a small team
we can we don't have to do everything
real real real in the animation how big
is a team six people helping us right
now is we're at a dish but like mostly
six of us well so look so what can
players expect as far as the length of
the game is it I did see boy it was a
roguelike game so how long will players
be in a narrative story driven game so
to do the full story it'll be about like
43 minutes it's like a premier episode
of television it's kind of how we look
at it like 45 in that zone where each
playthrough is shorter than that so
you'll be able to obtain persistent
items as what happened to him he just
died but you actually don't have died
you wake back up in the van as you were
adopting the dogs and you're veering off
the road the car and you're like oh my
god I just had a nightmare about the
horrible things that could happen to us
but it's her catastrophizing all these
scenarios but not actually in the
context
so it's a you're becoming more and more
prepared each time you run out there if
you find new items you get to keep them
you like I should have packed an axe
that would have been a smart plan and so
then she brings an axe with her like in
her later runs so that's how we built
this whole birthday with sounds like an
amazing game is super fun and it has
dogs in it so it's an automatic win so
but they need so much for your time
Lindsey thank you for talking about the
right Lantern one last question when can
people play the game and awards are
coming - yeah it'll be out later this
year we'll announce the date a little
closer to launch and it'll be on switch
Xbox Xbox game pass and epic game store
for PC take a look out for a Red Lantern
this is Lorin Maazel signing off the
Lord gave me dinette stay tuned for more
you
[Music]